Recently, you mentioned that sodium bicarbonate enabas
may stimulate the parasympathetic nervous system also,
which is great while I'm doing through it for these a week
as part of my protocol,
and you still recommend coffee enabas too.
So this person is doing enabas with sodium bicarbonate
instead of coffee.
So this person has colon cancer
and the purpose of doing sodium bicarbonate enabas
is that they're trying to get the sodium bicarbonate
up to the cancer itself so that the sodium bicarbonate
can break up the slide layer around the cancer
because that is acidic
and allow his immune system to be able to attack it a little better.
That's the idea of that.
The idea of coffee enabas has nothing to do with what I just said.
The purpose of a coffee enabas is to stimulate the vagal nerve
down at the rectal area of your colon.
The vagal nerve is responsible for a parasympathetic response.
So if you do to understand what that is,
go back and look at this blog and search parasympathetic
or sympathetic and you will see a blog post in a video
that comes up to explain what the difference
with parasympathetic and sympathetic is.
We want to stimulate the parasympathetics
because we live in a world of sympathetic overdrive
meaning that we're in a fight or flight, very high stress world,
especially when we have a serious diagnosis.
Our body has this constant inner exit
that you could only come back from an neurological perspective
by stimulating the parasympathetics
and calming the sympathetic in that blog post.
They also have written a paper on things to do
to call me or sympathetic.
The sympathetic are governed by a part of the brain
called the messencephalic center of the midbrain.
That's why it says the messencephalic colbyne exercises
and then the parasympathetics are controlled by the vagal nerve
so those are called vagal stimulating exercises.
The vagus is also a cranial nerve, 10.
So, you want to stimulate the parasympathetics
and calm the sympathetic.
You could do those concurrently.
There's a bunch of different exercises
that you could do with, we'll do that with.
And one of the best things for that is coffee enemas.
Coffee enemas stimulate that vagal nerve.
Sony macarbonate or chamomile enemas will do that also,
maybe to a little lesser degree.
So, the question is, should I still do coffee enemas on maybe
two, three days a week, the opposing days
that you're not doing the sodium macarbonate enemas?
You certainly can, yep, absolutely.
So, there's nothing wrong with doing that
as long as the coffee isn't irritating the tumor itself.
And we talked a little bit about that,
but I don't think it really was in your case.